so Tom Brady and Gisele I'm sorry guys I
can never say the last name I'm
officially divorced on October 28 2022.
legal teams from both say that and not
an ironclad prenup agreement was put in
place before they were married in 2009
making the financial aspects of the
divorce relatively smooth what has
happened since is there what has
happened since then and why are they
both in the new sense Giselle has been
linked with her children's Jujitsu
instructor Joe main Valentine a 42 year
old Brazilian man with some speculating
that they have had something going on
before the official divorce he started
appearing on giselle's social media
around February showing Giselle basic
techniques on Instagram he has also been
seen traveling with Giselle and the
children since the beginning of the year
Tom Brady 45 officially confirmed that
he is dating Veronica rajak a 26 year
old Slovakian model with over 3.2
million Instagram followers she she has
attended a few of a few of his games and
has taken photographs wearing his jersey
Gerard Peak and Shakira were in a
relationship from 2011 to 2022 having
two children during that time after
breaking up in 2022
Gerard Peak 36 years old has been
confirmed to be in a relationship with
23 year old Clara Chia Marty
Shakira has moved from Spain to her
family's home in Miami Florida and has
been linked to her 24 year old surfing
instructor custody of the children is
still pending this begs the question who
normally wins after high profile
breakups men or women
so we'll start here and then go around a
man or woman actually I think I managed
to hear what other people got to say
first I can't lie Okay who wants anyone
opinionated want to start come come on
just depends on how like what the
situation is so if there's obviously
kids involved
um
in high profile breakups oh
I say mendu okay yeah because
it's like no matter what the the
publicity just sort of like dies down on
them whereas women they get it a lot
more
that makes sense
I don't know
so I can't explain it so like some men
have more publicity after they say they
don't take it no they they get publicity
um
but it's not as much as like it wouldn't
go as long as what the woman's publicity
would go on for if that makes sense so
like there would be more Paparazzi
watching the wimp the woman
um her every move who she's dealt with
and then sort of like you'd hear once in
a blue moon if the man decides to leave
and show off that he's got a new woman
then they would catch him but it's like
a one-off one-off story and then that's
it bye okay that's what I see so you
would dictate who wins and loses after
the breakup by who has less publicity
yeah because it good all publicities can
be good but comes with bad as well a lot
of negative okay
I think after a high profile break up
right the women
the the Outlook from the society that
they get is kind of crazy I think they
get told
that they're not good for fine moving on
and finding someone else so and also
it's mostly men
in high profile breakups that money is
associated with as well so as soon as
the female goes and finds another
partner as always she like she doesn't
bother in the relationship she get it
and that's what I think and it's kind of
that's true if one a woman's moving from
relationship to relationship to
relationship then maybe she isn't the
best fit or the best candidate for a
relationship
I think a woman that moves from a
literature to a relationship knows what
she wants in a relationship because I'm
going to tell you not a lot of people
out there like are gonna be what you
want them to be so move I would say
personally move around as much as you
want until you find the right one
couldn't you figure that out before a
relationship like by asking certain
questions
um some things you have to live to
actually know because some people they
know stuff but in order how they apply
it practically is completely different
you can know so much but once you get
into a relationship it's way more
sacrifices way more compromisation that
gets involved that I think
is important and if you need to move
around as much as much relationships as
you need to to get that security to
finally understand that these situations
won't work for you then that's what you
might need to do and I think the more
women do get looked weirdly for that but
is what you've got to do at the end of
the day and then do it too so do you
think a guy is a good candidate for a
relationship if he's constantly having
failed situationships with women like if
he if he's maybe in a two-year span
dated like 20 girls do you think it's
likely he's going to date you
sorry I mean if I know Ahmad has dated
20 women otherwise should come date me
I'd kind of be like and but then it kind
of contradicts what I just said yeah but
at the same time as a man if a woman has
gone through 30 men and came up to me
and said I want a relationship with you
I'd kind of be that what's up you know
and also as much as I said
compromisation is required there are
stuff you have to learn and go through
sometimes you have to stick in a
relationship free to actually make stuff
work it doesn't necessarily be moving on
to other ones but just because you moved
on from relationship relationship to
relationship it doesn't mean you're
crazy
so
okay go ahead
um either of you you go ahead okay sorry
um so was this question reserved
specifically for high profile
relationships or uh just relationships
can you tell me your opinion on both
high profile and regular yeah sure so
high profile I think is a little bit
worse because say with them also can't
pronounce the name Gisele Bundchen I
think that's how you say it
um Tom Brady it's he's probably going to
be one of the most wealthy top 10 type
of men that she'll ever be with and
because women we're hyper and
hypergamous by Nature we typically can't
date down and she would struggle to find
someone especially at her age now that
she has children unfortunately and that
would give her what she wants which will
probably be marriage
um so I think that applies to most high
profile relationships because they have
some form of Celebrity Status therefore
their Partners will probably be a notch
ahead of them uh
whereas for normal people like us
um I think women generally unfortunately
still do losing a break in a breakup
um in the short term they're winning
because they can find a simp to buy them
a bag and take them places and they can
find men to fit different roles of a
partner but in the long term they would
lose because they'll struggle to
actually find someone who wants to be
with them and vice versa and they'll
probably get to say 35 No Children
because they've been playing the field
whereas if they stayed in the
relationship providing it's not abusive
you know the exceptions to the rule and
they try to make it work it probably
could have been happier
in the long term
I don't necessarily think that a breakup
means that you're gonna start sleeping
around start dating around I think some
women do wait I find men do move on
pretty quick and they seem to not be as
picky
I do think that they move on a bit
quicker
um I don't know I
I'm unsure of my opinion because there's
so many different variables like do they
have kids do they are they married were
they together for a long time I'm just
saying if there's a hundred high-profile
breakups high profile who typically wins
men or women can it be none of them
because there's so much drama around it
oh okay
um
I think the women the women yeah tell me
why because as I said the man moves on
very quick and he's not as picky and he
can seem to get a lot younger partner
than a woman would if a woman's had
children then there's that to
um so then the women lose
what did the women lose yeah it seems
like you're saying the man should get
like a younger what I'm saying is that
they can't move on maybe they want a
relationship after that breakup and it's
harder for them because they have
children maybe
um and then there's more to consider
it's not just black and white even
though the man has children as well when
they move on that's that doesn't seem to
hinder their day and experience they can
still date and move on and do what they
want it doesn't stop that
so it's just based on what you said it
sounds like you're saying that the women
lose and the men win yeah okay okay you
said the opposite when you started okay
I thought I said no I thought I said
that the women lose
I thought am I crazy maybe maybe yeah
maybe you did okay um go ahead
I think it's it is a difficult one it is
a broad one
um I think in if you're looking at high
profile celebrity status and breakups
um
I think generally depending on how they
break up I think it depicts on how it
would end up but probably women would
lose in terms of emotionally I think
especially if there's children as well
um pretty much
in times of
men I don't think they're emotionally
attached as much as women I think women
tend to be more emotionally attached
than men so
in a breakup I think when women break up
they break up way before they actually
physically break up with a man whereas a
man
I think they're quite flippant and they
will do it spare at the moment it's how
they're feeling so I think in terms of
who generally wins I would probably say
men in that aspect because I feel like
they're mentally their way before women
are probably there
okay what do you think
um
see I think the opposite to you I feel
like a woman knows in her head that
she's gonna break up with a guy
before
she's actually gonna do it yeah like the
other way around
I think yeah you just repeat it exactly
what she said my bad
um so yeah I feel like
when it comes to actually breaking up
I feel like women are more prepared for
that actually happening
then I don't think men think to
especially if they're comfortable in the
relationship
they're not really
thinking about it too tough so I would
say maybe men lose more because
I just think they're gonna they don't
see it coming as often do you think men
are more hurt after breakups than women
like women move on quicker Yeah okay or
like they start that process before yeah
because by the time the woman does that
she's been thinking about it for six
months what do you think about dating
options after do you think who do you
think typically has more dating options
after a relationship men or women
I think it depends on the man or the
woman right so in high profile cases
um
again I think it depends on the if you
had to pick one
maybe men in high profile okay cases
because I think for a high profile man
you'll have more women wanting to
do LP then the other way around
Auntie what do you think
at first I was in sight
before you put the sixes into it I was
gonna say the person with
the most money
wins initially because they're out of it
but then the women
are they actually it's the man and he's
got most money and they split up then
the woman might think she's winning
because she gets like money and the kids
and whatever
but then she's
less attractive
to the outside world so she might
thought she's a win she might think
she's one initially
but then I think the men in the end win
because they can get any woman out there
that they want younger that looks a
whole lot better than the old bag that
they've left so you know because all the
stretch marks and everything's gone and
because when you look at all of those
whoever had the most money
got someone younger
and even though their partner's gone and
football yeah like um
what do you call the the guy the perfume
the aftershave Guy what's his name the
one you just mentioned Tom Brady yeah
that's him the aftershave I don't know
they don't have to shave name like that
or something
you're thinking oh sorry yeah
okay I know it's something to do with
sports but
he split up and she's gone and she's got
this guy so when they said about women I
find that in the public eye sometimes
the women move on faster because
remember that's cautious because they've
lost a lot of money so they're not
moving on fast but afterwards they can
get a younger person
so the women were got there and they
would say oh we're going to get married
again are we going to get hooked up
we're going to settle down and the man
to just go out there and get a young
lady and play the field because they can
so the women might lose that you know
the men lose out more financially but in
the long run of course they got lucky
they can go and get any younger that
they want because when you're a mature
man and you've got money you're
attractive unlike
the women out there that got money
because like if they don't they don't
look all that all the plastic surgery
and stuff that they need to keep up
their looks but men just work out and
they'll still look good
can I say something
um Tom Brady so if you've specified it's
a high profile breakup then I'm guessing
we're talking about money here most of
the time I talk about popularity yeah
um can I ask when they actually got
divorced do you know when
um officially October 2022
okay okay right because I was gonna say
because as an athlete Tom Brady's
Spotlight the reason why hidden
Spotlight is always going to constantly
change like when he when he said he was
going to retire the spotlight was on
just retiring ain't nobody mentioned
about him breaking up but
I don't know I was all over the like my
YouTube feed yeah like there was it was
just on um right Megan Kelly just did a
special on it yeah right so I think my
main point so I'm trying to say here is
that the spotlight as an athlete but Tom
Brady is going to change constantly so
people are gonna eventually forget that
he's been divorced if he moves on with
another person so I think for the female
it's more so like she's the one that
broke up if Tom Brady is such a big deal
and I think the hate that's gonna come
for the women is more than it is for the
men just considering the fact that he's
such a high profile athlete would you
say in society men are valued more for
what they build where women are more
valued for the relationships they can
keep 100 100 because Tom Brady can now
do something crazy and invest in this
many stuff invest like a billion dollar
company maybe that's what's going to be
that's what he's going to be in the
spotlight for or it's like Elon Musk I
mean how many baby mothers does he have
but yeah no one H to their own isn't it
but no one really talks about it right
but if the roles were reversed and it
was a woman and she had the same company
but she had like three I don't know how
many he has but like three four baby
fathers people would still look at her
funny no matter how successful she is
it's gonna be long for her and that's
just how it is unfortunately as many of
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible